[Music]
it only in Canada news oh hey what nice
should happen now submitted by the grand
kazoo Oh
over 500 Canadian doctors protest their
own raises saying they're being paid too
much
oh so they said I can't do this a pay
too much please no more money decent
human being Steve no come on
yes damn yeah what is it what is too
much is it like half a million and
they're like that's too much bro so a
physician in Canada is paid two hundred
and sixty thousand nine hundred and
twenty four US dollars that's a lot
that's a good-ass amount that's weighted
like on average study more than here
yeah that's way more than here well
depending on the cost of look at the
pound City dependency Wow doctor fax
calm in here man [ __ ] about you here
here what aging and we just know these
things because we're supposed to be this
at least you sound like you know it yeah
I can't wait to look it up later know
I've gotten doc doctor talk my whole
life like you could be a doctor because
they make this much this kind of
benefits my whole life yeah but if it's
a area saturated in that hospital
already has the top of the top so for
example a vine has the highest I guess a
really good school district so
everyone's trying to get in right and a
lot of doctors are trying to get in so
it's oversaturated with qualified
doctors so the hospital there the local
hospital can give them a lower like I
guess rate and because there's so many
doctors so stuff like that they're only
they're only making like a hundred
something or whatever and it's like
that's crazy
so cheap I only know cuz I looked at my
friend [ __ ] okay your friends dark would
you guys like just dance
so more than 500 doctors and residue
as well as over 150 medical students
they all signed a public letter
protesting their own pay raises
hey we're kidding pay too much this is
what they said well we Quebec doctors
who believe in a strong public system
oppose the recent salary increases
negotiated by our medical Federation's
these increases are all the more
shocking because our nurses clerks and
other professionals face very difficult
working conditions while our patients
live with the lack of access to require
services because of the drastic cuts in
recent years and the centralization of
power in the Ministry of Health so
they're just saying that they are
offended that they would receive raises
when nurses and patients are also
struggling Union that's that they're up
against cuz it sounds like the ministry
or whatever negotiated this new rate
without their consent and it happened
and they're like what the hell you know
the medical Federation's part of the cap
at the top one more money cuz they're
gonna skim from that yeah yeah yeah and
well how honorable ya they saying that
the whatever money they're planning to
give them for the raises they want that
to be returned to the system instead so
that's that's amazing because that
doesn't happen here kind of interesting
though because it's like you could tell
that those physicians in that area
literally did not become a physician for
the monetary reasons yeah yeah I get
paid way more than I actually need and
then on top of that like I'm always
doing what I love so science they have
socialized medicine there right so it's
probably not gonna be as close to what
our doctors get when they specialized in
medicine and stuff yeah surgical
specialists in Canada they're paid three
hundred and fifty four thousand nine
hundred fifteen dollars that's
comparable to here my general surgeons
like three hundred something like
cardiologists like a heart surgeon
whatever start score to finally they get
socialized medicine but at the same time
they get paid as much the same that's
[ __ ] weird how does that work well
there's a whole different population up
there it's a whole different system I
feel like their DN B's are probably
really awesome too
I don't know they're if their medical is
socialized as ran by the government and
they're that well-paid and to the point
where their own workers are like you
know what we're getting pay too much but
they don't have a Paris
mentality like the way ours dra I'm
again in the DMV so I could be as lazy
as possible do it the minimal amount of
work Adam I still try to demand more
money on the government it's true just
some better people who maybe yeah a
because they're even saying that the
medical school in Canada is subsidized
that's amazing damn more reason to love
Canada dude - the chips I know our
country sucks dude yeah I child living
caboche coldest [ __ ] that still down I
love that we can exploit here okay for
business America is still the [ __ ] but
it sucks mom I just like California so I
don't know the rest of America we're
happy too much taxes out here paid too
much everything out here they want to
raise my gas tax but would you do that
would you move anywhere else I would
live in Texas yeah I like Texas it's
cheapest [ __ ] get the biggest house
in the entire world how stadium size
like 300 G let's move there I know I
want to see I don't think I'd mind that
taxes if I saw where like where it went
amen if we had medicine like Canada like
okay let's do it yeah it's not it's not
seeing a full picture just from this
little like there's some they have
problems up there with there's a medical
system like was I heard there's long
waits long waits and so like if you want
to get a hip replacement or something
you got to go to like Ohio if you want
to get it done this quick because
there's there's long lines yeah there's
also a certain percentage of population
I don't know if it's in Canada but I
know in like England that where people
who have treatable cancer it crosses the
threshold into untreatable because
they're waiting for treatment that kind
of [ __ ] goes on because of shortages and
yeah and lines and the healthcare
services provider on the basis of the
need all right so the thing out here is
is but you also got choice you go as fly
somewhere right is here we don't even
have that choice no no no people people
get treated here no matter what though
exactly and if you got the money you can
get whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
so if you're poor as hell like hospitals
won't refuse you even if you're
uninsured like you you'll you'll still
get and then there's a lot of those
clinics yeah yeah there's a lot of
low-income clinics as well as like if
you get injured or whatever
Hospital cannot refuse you they've got
to take care of you you might get hit
with a fatass bill but they're still
gonna take care a lot of the ridiculous
[ __ ] out here in my opinion is is the
way that all this [ __ ] works to the
insurance companies like doctors have to
like double triple whatever charge yeah
otherwise they don't see their money
yeah a huge part of it is the litigation
- I heard because the insurance is high
and all that because hospitals get sued
there's all these like there's just a
lot of money being drained from like I
think it's just patient greed as well as
different institutions [ __ ] up and
pharma companies so everyone's just
raping each other do they refuse
patients in Canada I don't know cuz I
mean we had a buddy that broke his arm -
and he was just in the waiting room for
eight hours
yikes in Canada no don't look here oh
yeah because you just see what
skateboarding broke his arm people that
died in the waiting room here yeah sure
I mean yeah the same thing happens here
like you get you get in a gunshot but I
mean like if you get a gunshot and if
you're like 12 down the line you still
gotta wait return
so you're just bleeding oh wait what do
mean in like an emergency situation they
bring you in
also it's based on trust my friend down
like he broke his arm II stopped waiting
there's probably gunshot guys in front
of him cuz he lives in LA yeah there's a
guy with a multiple stab wounds he's
like I got a lot of pressure here keep
holding this forever oh my god well I
remember when I was little and my uncle
he lit a firecracker near me or actually
that was the first time I was able to
light a firecracker so I was super
excited cuz I was a big kid now and I
got a little too close and then there
was sparks flying because it was one of
those that spin and they chase you so
they started chasing it started chasing
me like I'm forever scared of those
firecrackers I guess it is that one's
lit I'm booking you like I'm laying on
that one I like those and then so like a
pieces they work in water - you know I
fit on the pool yeah yeah it's in the
water I love doing that it's even
scarier you can't run like they're gonna
catch you wherever you go and I was like
the scariest moment
and one of those parts went in my eye
and then my all my eyelashes burnt off
and immediately I got so freakin scared
cuz I haven't at that she lost her eye
because the firecracker exploded in your
eye so that is the most Mexican like you
live and you went like this mmm
that's the difference between guys and
girls girls like oh my god I so [ __ ] its
girl guys if I look at my [ __ ]
eyelash there's a bird dog it's gone
it's gone family member with some
fucked-up [ __ ] because of fire I have a
cousin that lost like these two fingers
or some fireworks
yeah those explode I don't know why he
held him with boom oh my gosh well the
one that my aunt lost her eye to
apparently was it was near a car or
something like they put it between like
the side mirror or something she was
near she didn't know it was being lit
that's like oh that's whoa near her and
then her I just got all burned
so anyway I'm looking in the mirror and
I see everything's like before my
eyelashes are all crispy like a homeless
girl starts getting all white like
there's like white film that starts
going over it and I'm like I'm gonna
lose my eye I'm gonna be like damn I'm
not gonna have an idol and I'm just
going to think how cool it would be to
have an iPad that's exactly what I was
thinking yeah [ __ ] this I I patched on
that's pretty hot cuz remember Black
Mamba was it black mamba before Kill
Bill came out well the Raiders the
[ __ ] if that white [ __ ] if you have
that white [ __ ] over your eyelids you've
anything you say sounds mystical James
Bond villain that's right exactly that
to go so pessimistic my mom took me to
the ER and she just kept saying since I
saw myself in the mirror in the house
she just kept saying like don't look in
the mirror don't look and the more she
kept telling me don't look at my I was
getting worse it was gonna like fall out
that white [ __ ] I mean I'm not a doctor
I look like a nerd it was probably
nothing at all you're just freaking the
[ __ ]
they did end up giving me oh man I had a
patch and like I had a patch guy oh yeah
we did a cool eyepatch or was it just
Gaza in time you got a little Halloween
store rip that [ __ ] off a real path I
always wanted an eyepatch no and I was
just way too slippery to bite now you
definitely get one we have like three of
them in the process it's not the same
when you have a working eye underneath
there oh man oh my god I've actually
that doesn't have the strings or
whatever it's just the iPad 18 [ __ ] is
that the Morpheus is like the sticky bra
it's like in every Marvel movie now they
have like those in my sunglasses duffle
just like yeah but he's in quick uture
does even have things on the side sick
looking
[Music]
[Music]